ladies and gentlemen deckley has
responded brace yourselves he's gone
full damage control panic mode including
calling me racist for exposing his scam
and he literally doxed me in a post
which he has now deleted but we'll get
into all of that for now let's back up
and talk about his response video and
explain what is this situation how did
we get here well i uploaded a video
right here accusing million token a coin
tech lead created of being a ponzi coin
that tech lead lied about and scammed
his fans with for millions of dollars
additionally he said he put in a million
dollars of his own money i'm putting a
million dollars of my own money into
this to get us started but now admits
that isn't true and you know to clarify
okay when i started the project i
bootstrapped with 50 000 usd coins
paired to 50 000 million tokens but
despite that lie tech lead seems to be
doubling down because on sunday he
responded with a video that frankly is
unbelievable it's called i'm so sorry
i'm going to jail as a millionaire let's
take a watch together and see where it
all went wrong ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the 10 million dollar studio
i'm your host coffee zilla and don't
forget to pump the stock that's not a
stock zilla guys it's free you just like
subscribe and the dividends they start
rolling in now getting into this
response video right up front let's put
the cans on let's dodge the board let's
do it guys um right here here it is guys
the big response video first of all tech
lead looks a little sad oh
that like dislike isn't doing so well
okay let's throw him a like there i'm
here for you tech looks like he could
use it but let's get into this
catastrophe
together how's my hair looking sharp
you know it's tough being successful
it's lonely at the top
as they say the road to hell is paved
with good intentions or
sorry what i meant to say was that i
think we really have a chance of going
to the moon so basically right away
techlee doubles down and says that
helium token is doing better than ever
making a moon landing with million token
the hottest cryptocurrency right now on
social media in fact just recently
million token has been trending on
subreddit on coin gecko most visited
most trending cryptocurrency now this is
the beginning of the reality bubble of
tech lead it's a manipulator tactic
where you try to repeat a lie long
enough to make it true he'll do that
throughout this story but the reality of
million token is this it's a crypto
that's down about 80 percent but if you
listen to tech lee tell it sounds like
it's at all time highs and the reason
the person you have to thank for that is
apparently me it's because of so much
press recently what do we have to thank
for this coffeezilla oh the big bad bad
wolf gonna blow your ponzi coin down get
ready don't listen to me guys don't
don't listen to me why he goes around
basically calling project scams and
maybe he generates some good press for
himself he virtue signals and then
people think that he's a hero for
calling everything a scam life is a scam
okay he's a hero this is really just
victim mentality victim mentality guys
you don't want victim mentality tech
lead is very much against it sure life's
unfair and you can complain about
everything out there you can say that
government's a scam but what are you
really going to do about it wow this guy
hates victim mentality which is weird
because right after this video due to
the likes and dislikes he went on a
unhinged twitter rant where he tried to
accuse me of being racist against him
apparently that's the only explanation
for why i called his coin a scam is
coffeezilla racist his hatred for asian
people like myself is really unjustified
now that's an interesting strategy
pulling the race card let's see if it
pays off for him guys because the only
problem is tech lead doesn't even agree
with tech leads own use of the race card
ability is that early on i just decided
i don't really want to be playing the
race card everywhere i go yeah guys he
would never do such a thing play the
race card why well because according to
him doing so would be a victim mentality
which tech lead would never have you
just start blaming other people for your
position and you just take on the victim
mentality the victim mindset and you
start saying it's because i was born in
this way it's because you're being
racist against me hmm that didn't turn
out so well uh you look like a giant
hypocrite right there you're saying
don't listen to coffeezilla he's the guy
with the victim mentality and also
people who play the race card have a
victim mentality and then because you
can't ha you don't have any arguments oh
you you play the race card i mean maybe
this guy maybe you guys should listen to
tech lead guys maybe you shouldn't
listen to the guy playing the victim
mentality but moving back to the video
uh the biggest annoyance i had in this
video you know before it went full
delusional is just kind of the
disappointment that tecly didn't
actually address any of my points
something that the commenters picked up
on quote i don't want to brush off his
accusations brushes off zilla's
accusations a 10-minute response video
where none of the major claims are
addressed dude the first thing you did
was attempt to play the race card how
can you sit there and mention the victim
mentality with a straight face you
dodged every valid question and then
tried to compare yourself to a pirate
now hold on we might be getting ahead of
ourselves with the pirate thing but
these guys these commenters are right
techlee doesn't address the substantial
criticism so it's kind of annoying and
in that sense i don't have too much to
add there because if you're not gonna
address the fact that like your coin is
a ponzi scheme what am i supposed to say
exactly but one thing i can add is that
to my surprise i found out the tech lead
a few months ago actually agreed with me
that ponzi schemes are bad check it out
recently some information has come to
light that has made me skeptical about
this whole cryptocurrency market
thinking that the whole thing could be
being pumped up by a ponzi scheme and i
wanted to make this video quickly to
warn any of you out there as well who
may have substantial life savings of
your own also in cryptocurrencies
so a few months ago he's calling out
ponzi schemes when i guess it was
financially convenient and socially
convenient to do so but then i guess he
figured out um if you can't beat him
why not join him and this pattern of
tech lead calling out scams and then
doing the exact opposite doesn't even
stop there uh he also called finance a
scam a while back but what we need to
talk about today is something extremely
serious which are the exit scams and
people getting rock pulled losing
potentially their life savings this is
exactly what happened with people over
in binance so here he is calling out
binance but hey what's this the video
has been unlisted
why maybe it's because tech lead is now
trying to get million token listed on
binance here he's tweeting binance
listing at the ceo so tech lead calls
out the scam until it's time for him to
run a scam and then he pretends that
what i do it's virtue signaling it's a
victim mentality he goes around
basically calling project scams and
maybe he generates some good press for
himself he virtue signals ah
so tech lead calls out scams when it's
convenient and when he's getting praised
to do so but the second it's more
convenient for him to run his own scam
suddenly it's it's virtue signaling to
do what i do it's so funny to me to
watch tech lee completely contradict
himself every few months whenever he
finds a new grift or he needs to do it
it's expedient for him to completely
change his value system
but there is one point techlee did
address of mine and this was the part
where i said he lied about saying that
he put a million dollars of his own
money into million token and guess what
he admits i'm right and you know to
clarify okay when i started the project
i bootstrapped with 50 000 usd coins
paired to 50 000 million tokens that's
exactly what i said so he's admitting it
he did not put in a million dollars of
his own money he used your money i had
already collected about 100 000 usd
coins so i use those to continue
deploying more tokens which would bring
in more usd coins and now he tries to
weasel out of this by saying
oh it's still backed by a dollar
whatever the bottom line is he lied
about the exact like launch statement of
his coin i'm putting a million dollars
of my own money into this to get us
started he lied he just admitted it i
mean it's a scam folks but this is where
the video really takes a turn for the
delusional because besides avoiding all
the major points tech lead it seems like
decides to go mask off villain mode um
because he essentially said the fact he
brought bad press to his own project was
actually a good thing and so it's kind
of like genghis khan napoleon or captain
blackbeard these iconic historical
figures and you know some of these
people were even villains sure you could
say that captain blackbeard was a
scammer he even killed people and yet
they are legends in history and there is
a value with these people yo this man
really just said yes blackbeard killed
people yes he was a scam but isn't it
cool that you know his name
no
and by the way you're not a legend
you're on coffeezilla like that doesn't
make you famous but this tells you so
much about the psychology at play here
it's all about fame that's all that
matters to tech lead it's an illness
that clout chasers have it's like
followers are the only thing that
matters and anything that gets you
followers must be good and honestly it's
cringy it really reminds me of this guy
that was seen on dr phil i mean you'd
look at this guy and think he's got a
mental illness i mean i don't talk to my
family
what uh they're irrelevant
they're irrelevant none of them have
followers if they got followers or got
rich i'd probably talk to them again
hang on a minute did you just say i
don't talk to my family because they
don't have followers
if they had followers they'd be here
right now this is honestly the tech lead
mentality it's like hey all that matters
is followers good press bad press what
does it matter guys it's all about being
a a legend you got to be a legend and if
you're wondering does tech lead really
believe this just listen to what he has
to say right after that clip i bet that
if i were to get arrested and go to jail
the price of million token would
skyrocket because it would just be
legendary you know like it took this
millionaire down it ended this guy's
career it destroyed his reputation this
was the cryptocurrency that did it in
for this guy look this is unhinged this
is delusional like first it's factually
wrong look at the price of something
like i don't know bit connect you know
after people were first like were
arrested the price did not exactly
skyrocket for coins that turn out to be
scams but secondly getting put in jail
doesn't make you a legend it makes you a
criminal and criminals are a dime a
dozen you're not cool if you're a
criminal but here's the thing you can't
talk sense to somebody like tech lead
right it doesn't work and the reason is
he thinks he's smarter than everybody
what do you respect do people like
coffeezilla and i'm sure that he works
hard and he's got the best of intentions
i'm just operating at a totally
different level than him right so like
if he's operating here i'm like up here
i'm pretty up there
it's literally the i'm the big brain
meme it's like talking about how how
high your iq is hey hey i belong to
mensa
like everybody else coffee's a lot down
here me up here that's this is the level
where you say i don't play the race card
and then play the race card it's just
you wouldn't understand guys it's a
level you're not at you and me we're not
there and look unfortunately you can't
reason with people who think they're up
here they believe they're superior to
everyone else until it's time to play
the victim card and then they're of
course happy to play that too but um
that's basically the whole video tech
lead acts like he's gonna address all my
points never does goes on a rant about
how getting arrested would be great for
his coin and then when his back is
against the wall because people are
seeing through his manipulation tactics
and down voting video he goes on twitter
and tries to call me racist which he
said he would never do early on i just
decided i don't really want to be
playing the race card everywhere i go
you just start blaming other people for
your position and you just take on the
victim mentality the victim mindset oh
and uh
i almost forgot like yeah he also tried
to dox me yeah i almost left that out of
this piece using an old debunked piece
of blackmail that we talked about in
this video remember this is the thing
swag academy tried to catch me out on
but uh retracted immediately because
it's literal blackmail and a dox now i'm
blurring out most of it for obvious
reasons but look at what he said he goes
want some hard facts coffeezilla is a
reported
and then of course you have the
obligatory this is why lions do not
concern themselves with the opinions of
sheep
this is so insane defamatory fully
debunked that when i saw it i laughed
because i was like oh this guy must be
completely out of options if this is the
best he can come up with trying to smear
me with anything and everything he can
find and not even trying to fact check
it and of course i immediately dm'd him
told him it was defamatory and to his
credit he deleted it and put up a
statement correction on the last tweet
to be fair the allegations on coffee
were later debunked he's got haters
apparently and i appreciate him
correcting the record this is obviously
the right thing to do but let's make no
mistake here it's wrong to dock somebody
period even if it didn't contain
blackmail which in this case it did and
don't forget the same thing happened to
trin black after he criticized matt tran
and tech lead but people for some reason
gave tech lead a pass in this case i
wonder if they're gonna give him a pass
again to dox people and everyone just
seems to be fine with it i don't know
i'm sickened by this but honestly i
think it's a distraction from the real
point which is the actual arguments
against million token going completely
unaddressed he still profited millions
from his followers he still ran ads
about his scam and lied about his
ownership in those ads he still created
a ponzi coin after saying ponzi schemes
are bad he still called critics racist
after saying he'd never play the race
card he docks his critics when they try
to call him out and he's still trying to
gaslight his way out of it with his fans
whether it works is i guess up to you
guys but either way we here at
coffeezilla headquarters well we're
gonna continue to try to um keep
unearthing these schemes
and shining a light for everyone in this
crypto space that's basically it thanks
for watching smash like and subscribe to
pump the zilla and i'll see you in the
next one
all the
[Music]
a promises are you the same as choice